in this talk we're gonna talk about
using blazer to build full stack web
apps using just dotnet and c-sharp now
Don that has always had a great story
for building server rendered web apps
these are apps where you stick some
dotnet code on ur server and that code
generates HTML or Jason in response to
browser requests if you wanted to do
anything on the client in the browser
well that meant you had to use one of
these guys you had to write some
JavaScript and there's lots of great
things about JavaScript but there's also
some additional cost and overhead of
having to bridge these two very
different developer worlds with
different languages different frameworks
and different tools well this is no
longer the case you can now write your
client-side web app logic using net with
blazer blazer is a client-side web UI
framework where you get to write net and
c-sharp instead of JavaScript you write
UI components that encapsulate your UI
logic using c-sharp and razor you can
then share your dotnet code the same
assemblies on both the client and the
server if you've got some validation
logic you can use it on both sides of
the wire if you need to call into
JavaScript code you can still do that
you should have access to all the
JavaScript API is of the browser and
other libraries through a JavaScript
Interop mechanism now Blaser is in large
part made possible thanks to a
relatively new open web standard called
web assembly what is web assembly well
web assembly is a bytecode for the web
the idea is that if you can compile your
code to web assembly it can now run in
any browser on any platform at near
native speeds and we've been working for
a while now on getting dotnet to run
great on web assembly we are building a
dotnet runtime in web assembly this is
how a blazer web assembly app works the
browser provides the core web assembly
support on top of that we've built a
dotnet web assembly runtime you then
build your razor components that get
compiled into normal dotnet assemblies
they're downloaded with the runtime into
the browser and then executed directly
in the browser
the browser then sends all its UI events
to your dotnet code your components run
they render their UI
and blazer does all the hard work to
figure out what exactly changed in the
UI the difference is then sent back to
the DOM and updated very very
efficiently now the cool thing about
blazer though is that you can host it in
multiple different ways we've talked
about running your app on webassembly
but alternatively you can also run your
blazer apps and host them on the server
using the same components the way I
blaze our server app works is your
components run on the server the browser
sets up a real-time signal our
connection with the the server and
that's what it uses to handle and send
all of the UI events that the the user
is is creating when a button click
occurs it gets sent to the server the
corresponding component runs just like
it did on a blizzard players blazer
webassembly app the component renders
that the Blazer does that hard work of
calculating ad if it C realises that
diff back down that real-time connection
back to the browser so can it be applied
to the Dom so in dotnet core 300 we've
shipped support for blazer server apps
you can use that in production today go
and download it and install it and I was
thrilled to that we announced today in
the keynote earlier that blazer
webassembly apps will be shipping and
supported in May of next year now how do
you pick between these two different
hosting models well there are different
pros and cons to each a blazer
webassembly app that is really a true
single page app it has full
interactivity
it runs client-side on the user's device
you can use all that users device
devices resources like it's CPU its
memory its storage to the extent that
the browser will let you it supports
offline scenarios you can you can deploy
it as a static site you don't even need
to have dotnet running on the server
because your app is just a bunch of
static files you can build progressive
web apps with a blazer web assembly the
downsides of blazer web assembly are
well you need to download that runtime
with your app and that means an
additional download size cost so your
app may load slower it does also require
that the browser supports web assembly
and while all modern browsers
do if you need to support something like
say ie11 or an older browser that
doesn't have webassembly support then
this one's not going to work for you
also blazer webassembly is still in
preview it's not ready for production
yet so that's a factor to consider as
well
blazer server apps they have a really
small download because the only thing
they need to download is a little piece
of infrastructure code that sets up that
real time signal our connection your
blazer component code is now running on
the server on a full dotnet core runtime
and it has access to all of the
resources that the server has access to
do you want to talk directly to the
database you can do that from a blazer
server app some people really like that
your code never leaves the server in a
blazer server app if you're
uncomfortable with the idea that your
dll's will get downloaded into the
browser and the user can grab them and
decompile them then maybe a blazer
server app will be a better choice it
can really simplify your architecture to
not have to stand up additional Web API
endpoints and so forth so on in order to
access server resources because you're
already there you're running on the
server the cons of the blazer server
model are first of all latency all of
your UI interactions are going to go
over the network so you're going to want
to make sure that your clients and the
server are as close together as possible
there's only so much you can do about
the speed of light
it's a connected model so obviously no
offline support and also you're paying
with your server resources to run the UI
for each connected client so that's an
additional scale and cost consideration
how do you get started with blazer well
I recommend going to blazer net that's
where you can find all of the getting
started instructions and the blazer
Doc's you're going to want to install
dotnet core 3 o if you're interested in
playing around with blazer web assembly
you'll need to install the Blazer web
assembly template too if you're on
Windows using Visual Studio make sure
you get Visual Studio 2019 16.3 which is
now available today as well if you're on
Mac or Linux user you can use Visual
Studio code to do blazer development
using the c-sharp extension and we are
working on Rich's studio for Mac support
for blazer as well and it should be
coming soon
alright let's take a look at blazer
let's write some blazer code
so I'm gonna go into Visual Studio and I
have here the same blazer weather app
that you may have seen earlier in the
keynote this is a single page app that
lets us see the current weather of
Seattle where work where we're close to
where we're currently at today and you
can see as usual Seattle it is raining
alright so that's pretty cool now how we
didn't really get a chance in the
keynote to take a look at how this app
is running and this is the same app I
did refactor it slightly to move all the
components back into the app project
just to simplify things a little bit
let's take a look at how this project is
structured the first thing to notice is
that a blazer server app and this is a
blazer server app is just an asp.net
core application here's the program CS
file for the app it's got the normal
asp.net core hosting coke boilerplate
code in here it has a startup class that
defines the startup logic for the
application in this configure services
method this is where we define all of
the services for the that we want
available through dependency injection
for our app up above you can see that
we're adding the services for both razor
pages and Blaser server which is
interesting Blaser remember is a
client-side UI framework it does not
replace or remove the need for the other
server rendered frame roofs you still
want to be able to run code on both the
server and the client Blazers for the
client these two pieces of technology
are meant to be used together and we'll
see more about that in just a bit
this apps also setting up an HTTP client
to be used to talk to the back-end
weather forcast service that you saw
glenn build earlier and then we have
some other apps specific services that
we'll talk about in a bit down below in
our configure method this is where the
apps request handling pipeline is being
set up most of this code is boiler
plates the same set of middleware that
every asp.net core app has the two
things that are different is here you
can see we're setting up the blazer hub
this is the signal our hub that believes
our users for managing all of the UI
interactions with the browser and then
lastly there's this map fall back to
page route what is this all about well
this is going to take any request that
makes it to this point and make it go to
underscore our host it'll basically
reroute it to this endpoint what's that
underscore or host let's go take a look
well underscore our host dot C s HTML is
just a razor page remember we're using
razor pages and blazer together both
sides of the wire
most of the content in this page looks
pretty normal looks like normal HTML but
there are two things that are kind of
different the first is at the bottom
there's this script tag this is where
we're adding the Blazer server che s
script which is provided by the
framework this is the script that sets
up the real-time signal our connection
with the hub that we saw previously we
also have this HTML helper this render
component async call what is this doing
well this is rendering this the the apps
root component right here on this racer
page for the initial render of the app
and there's nothing special about this
app component this could be any
component you want and you can render
any component you want onto any MVC view
or any razor page let me show you this
is really the case so let's I've have a
different project over here not not the
weather app this is just a vanilla MVC
app and asp.net core MVC app I just did
file new project and then I added those
things that you just saw from the Blazer
server app in the startup class I added
server-side blazer down in the endpoints
I added the Blazer hub we don't need the
fallback route in this case goes we're
not going to be using routing we're just
going to be having individual components
on pages and then in the apps layout
which i think is under here and shared
there it is you can see down here at the
bottom I've also added the Blazer server
script all right so we should be all set
to go to use components in our MVC app
now I've added a component to this
project as well it's right here
component 1 dot raiser it's pretty
simple this namespace is important for
getting all of the web related RAZR
directives to light up so if you're
having problems with those directives
not compiling for some reason make sure
you've got it using for this namespace
it's it's it's needed and then we have
an input in a P tag and we're using this
at bind directive what is that well that
is setting up a two-way data bind
between the value of the input and this
message field that's on my blazer
component and then I render out the
current message down below you can also
see that I'm changing which event
is used for the bind normally a bind on
an input would occur on change here have
decided to do it every time I touch the
keyboard on every key press so on input
so I should see this message update with
every keyboard press now to add a
component to a project it's really easy
you can just do add new item and there's
a razor component item template that you
can use that's what I use to create this
this component okay let's now add this
to one of my views I'm gonna go to the
home page of this app and I don't
remember the HTML helper so I'm just
gonna copy it let's go grab this piece
of code and put it right there in my MVC
view I don't want to render the app
component I want to render my component
one component components are just normal
dotnet classes so that's why you can
just use the type name the type name
comes from the name of the file okay
that should be it let's go ahead and run
it and we should see a vanilla MVC app
with the normal default template styling
and hopefully a component let's see yeah
there's my component let's let's zoom in
a little bit and if I just start mashing
the people were like hi dotnet coffee
you can see it's doing the data binding
we have an interactive component on an
MVC view okay great so that's using
blazer from MVC apps or basis or pages
apps if you have an existing app which
I'm guessing many of you do you can use
blazer with that app if there's no need
to rewrite an app to be blazer you use
blazer for your client-side concerns
okay let's go back to the Blazer weather
application we've seen I think
everything in underscore hosts at CS
HTML let's look at that app dot raiser
component here it is this is just
setting up client-side routing for the
application it's gonna find all the
routable components in this assembly
let's go see what routable components we
have well it turns out we only have one
and that's this forecast dot RAZR
component you can tell it's routable
because it has the app page directive at
the top you do need to explicitly
specify the route at some point maybe
we'll infer that from the file path but
for right now for Blazer components you
need to explicitly specify it ok so
there's only one page in this app so
this truly is a single page application
ok and then down below for most of the
bring logic for the forecast page it's
just razor syntax a mix of HTML and C
sharp like this get background class
function is returning some code for a
class based on whether it's daytime or
nighttime and what the current
temperature is if it's a you know a warm
temperature or a cold temperature so
just some c-sharp and HTML now some
people get kind of concerned because
down here at the bottom we have that
code block again and there's all this
code that's in my component some people
get concerned about this mixture of code
and markup and it was that really okay
never used to say you're supposed to
always separate those things and you
should separate code from your
components if that code is like business
logic but if it's related to the
presentation layer it's perfectly fine
to have it in line in the file I mean
it's going to be compiled into the same
class anyway but if you still prefer the
code behind pattern that's fine you can
do that too if you remember from the
keynote in the forecast page we have
this little temperature picker component
let's go look at the app that's this
this guy right here if I click it it
switches the temperature unit from
Celsius to Fahrenheit and back that
components implemented over here in the
components folder and it's pretty simple
it's got a div and a couple of spans but
it does have some code if you don't like
that code living in the component here's
how you do it you're gonna add a new
class you're gonna call it the same
finally temperature unit Picard razor
dot see us and if you did it right it
should nest nicely underneath it did
alright great and then I usually call
this is gonna be an inheritance model
the the code behind will be a base class
so I usually call the base class the
same name as the component with base and
it needs to derive from component base
let's get the namespace for that good
and then you can just copy all the code
out of the code block put it into your
base class save it we do need to change
the visibility of this private method
because this is an inheritance pattern
so now needs to be protected so that it
can be visible by the derived component
class and then let's just inherit from
our base class using the at inherits
directive so hat inherits temperature
unit picker base okay and that's what
you do and if we wait a second hopefully
all those red squiggles will go away as
it picks up the base class
there goes ok so that's how you can do
code-behind if you like this pattern I
prefer the inline pattern so I'm gonna
keep that I'm gonna delete what I just
did
and leave it the way it was alright
great so that's that's that let's look a
little bit more our forecast page now
Mike made some changes to some files
after we load the browser now one of the
things that's not so nice about this app
is that the location is hard-coded like
you only get the weather for Seattle
it'd be nice if we could actually see
the the weather for some more plate more
places like maybe we could search for
our location or maybe even use the
current location of the user based on
the their their browser how can we add
that alright so let's try and add some
location search capability let's add it
using a component so I have a location
search dot razor file over here in my
components folder and this is gonna
allow the user to search for places and
it's got some very simple markup very
little it's got a div with an image this
image is just a little search icon that
shows if a search query is in progress
like it'll spin a little spinner thing
if you're currently searching for
locations it has an input and this input
is data a list a list driven input the
data list for this input is defined
below and then we are binding the value
of the input to this search query
property very similar to what we saw
before in the MVC app and we're binding
on every single keystroke
what we want is every time the user type
starts typing we're gonna kick off a
search and try and autocomplete for them
with this text box okay so let's see now
this this search query property is
pretty clever now it has a setter that
if the search query value is not null or
empty then it's gonna do this search
debounce
method what is that guy well you
probably don't want to do you know a
back-end request with every single time
the user types on the keyboard that
might be a little bit too much too much
too chatty so instead this is gonna be
bounce which means it's going to wait
for the user just sort of pause typing
and things sort of see if they're done
and so there's some clever code in here
it's using a you know cancellation token
source and it cancels the previous
search if there was one in progress and
then does a delay and it keeps checking
to see if the search was cancelled while
it's in the process of doing this
this query and here you can see here's
where they're the weather forecast
service is being asked for the current
location based or locations based on the
text from the query and then if it has
still hasn't been cancelled and it saves
the set of returned locations to this
location field which is just in a
location array and that's what we're
using to generate the data list that you
the user can then pick from from the
location text box cool now the user
needs to also be able to pick a location
and so that's what this on change event
handler is for at the end here on that
same input when the user actually
selects a particular location or hits
enter and then this location selected
method gets hot called what is this
doing well it's getting the selected
location and then it's raising a
callback so that the parent component
can know what the location was that was
that was chosen this location changed
property is of type event callback it's
a component parameter which means it can
be provided by the parent component as a
piece of code to call when this event
has has occurred all right so let's
let's wire up this component in our
forecast page so let's go up here and
we're going to do right under here let's
do location search location changed
equals location change is the name of
the method I have defined already on the
forecast component all right so now we
should have a location textbox what does
this component do when the location
actually changes well it cancels the
real time updates to the weather that
we're in progress previously and then
kicks off another async for each loop to
get new updates from for the new
location so that's what it's gonna do if
we go back to the app now hopefully we
can see this working all right so now we
have a textbox let's try and type
something so let's try like Chicago all
right we get our drop-down we can pick
it let's try New York having our little
spinny things working great so that's
working so now we can search for
locations but I'd also like to be able
to just use the the users current
location have them you know use the
browser's native capability to detect
the user's location with its geolocation
API so that would be cool
but those api's are in JavaScript which
means
have to write some JavaScript I don't
want to have to write some JavaScript
Blaser does have JavaScript Interop
capabilities you can call from dotnet
into JavaScript and back and it does a
lot of that for you that's how it
manipulates the the Dom but I so I could
write my own I could use those same
abstractions but fortunately most of the
time you don't actually have to do that
because someone in the blazer community
has already done it for you so I've
added a package to this application let
me look at my new kit packages
here's the install packages you could
see I have this asp net monster's that
blazer that geolocation package this is
a package that was actually written
quite a while ago in the early days of
blazer here's the the URL for the the
github location the code was was a
little stale again we have we had
changed the api's a bit and it broke
this package so i had to fork it and fix
it up a little bit but pull request was
submitted so hopefully I need it any day
now that will get merged and this
package will then be up to date with the
latest blazer release but I'm just going
to use this package to call the browsers
geolocation API is here's the code for
that package so you can see what that
looks like
that's typescript let's let's not look
at that let's look at this she's sharp
okay here's the location service class
provided by this package and you can see
it's taking an IJ s runtime service
that's provided by blazer for doing
JavaScript Interop and the way you use
it is by calling invoke async and invoke
async takes a string which is the
JavaScript function that you want to
call you can pass in additional
parameters let's dotnet objects that
will get serialized and sent them over
to JavaScript and then the generic
parameter is the the return type so
that's how you can call into JavaScript
fortunately I don't have to do that
because I think it's simon tim's is the
guy who wrote this project so it's great
he already did it for me and he took
care of writing all this complicated
javascript so that's awesome so i don't
have to do that let's go back to blazer
weather and use his package instead so
I've already installed his package you
may have seen in the startup class I
added his geolocation service i reaiiy
put an alias for it to call it
geolocation service as a injectable
service in my app and then in the
location search component at the top you
can see I'm at injecting the geolocation
service so I can use it alright where do
we want to use that well when this image
this is the third image this has that
that's that little target button when it
is clear
we're gonna call get local weather what
does that method do well this methods
just going to call the geolocation
service and get the geolocation and then
it's going to use the weather forecast
service passing in the latitude and
longitude to resolve that to a location
that we can then use to update the
weather so hopefully that just works
let's go back to the weather app if I
click on the target you can see the
browser saying do you want to allow this
app to use your current location yes
let's see where I'm currently at where
am I really I'm in Redmond that's
actually correct and that is the correct
weather for Redmond alright so that's
how you can get the current location
using an API that's reaction written in
JavaScript but as far as I can as far as
I'm concerned it's like it was written
in c-sharp I'd also like to be able to
pin some of these locations so that I
can go back to them instead of having to
keep search for them how could we do
that
well I groped a little push pin
component there it is and this is just a
custom checkbox that I got the markup
from over the web it has an is checked
parameter and is checked changed event
callback so this and this has been
styled to look like an actual push pin
so let's let's go ahead and put this
onto our forecast page and where should
we put this this will need to go let's
put it right by the location pushpin and
we want to say is checked we're going to
bind that to the current location is and
it hasn't is pin property so that we can
tell whether it's been pinned and then
that's a wire up the event callback to
call our pin location method that I've
already defined on the forecast
component so if we go look at pin
location here's what it's doing it's
keeping track of all the pin locations
into just a collection and in keeping
track of which pin location as was shown
last using this pin location index and
we also need some buttons so we can
cycle through those locations I've
already got those defined here so I'm
just going to copy them in let's see
where do we put those let's put them by
the image I'm gonna like the little
carrots on either side of the image
these are just two little carrot images
that again have on click handlers
defined when these handlers are called
it just changes what the current index
is of the the
location all right so if we reload the
app now hopefully we should be able to
see a little pin icon you see that right
there we could be able to pin Seattle
let's do a Honolulu looks good yeah
let's pin that and then oh it's not and
it's not showing that why am I'm not
showing up what'd I do wrong I forgot
something back winner oh it's what I
forget the pin location is there oh did
I not say I always forget to save ah
yeah I didn't save go back so we had we
did I hoped I save for the pin the pin
but not for the actual you extra UI so I
could cycle through so Chicago let's pin
this one so pin Seattle Chicago let's
pin that yeah now we got our icon so we
can cycle through okay so you get that
point so there we've done some some
blazer development and that sample will
be available up later for you to play
around with now if this is not obviously
we don't have enough time to go through
all that's available in blazer I highly
encourage you to go check out our blazer
workshop where you can learn to build
this awesome
British pizza store and that will teach
you all about the different parts of the
blazer component models a big shout out
to our component vendors telluric that
Express sink fusion they've the
wonderful blazer come component
libraries that you can use Radzin is
also a component vendor and they ship a
low code solution where you can build
blazer apps with just a designer that's
pretty awesome you should check that out
another big shout out to our blazer
community thank you Chris dainty who has
provided us packages for local storage
which is actually part of this sample
app and also Simon for the geolocation
API so if you want to check out lots of
great projects in the community I
encourage you to go to an awesome blazer
AKMs / awesome blazer it's a github repo
that keeps links to all different
articles videos tutorials samples and
libraries one of my favorites is this
blasteroids sample I'm just going to
show it really fast and then I'll get
off the stage blasteroids is a blazer
webassembly app I think it's hosted on
github pages but it is doing like full a
full like version of the 1980s asteroids
app written in dotnet on webassembly
that's pretty awesome alright that
I've got glazier servers available today
download and install it and start doing
full stack development with dotnet and
c-sharp thank you
awesome Dan thank you so much those so
cool okay so we have a ton of questions
and excitement about phlaser where
should we start
how about Oh which one did we have they
jumped around again things are moving we
we had one week that we promised well
here's a quick i'll just don't remember
where it is on the screen but it was a
question about browser compatibility are
there any browsers that we need to worry
about is this something that works
everywhere for Blazer on the server it
works with all the modern browsers as
long as you can set up that WebSocket
connection for older browsers you may
need some polyfills to get it to work
but those polyfills are available and a
lot of them are maintained by the
community for a web assembly you need a
browser that supports web assembly so if
you don't support web assembly you're
kind of out of luck so like ie 11 you're
not gonna be running blaze or
webassembly apps on ie love it gotcha
alright so I can't find blazer project
templates and visuals to be for Mac any
idea when we'll be adding yeah Visual
Studio for Mac is coming we are working
with him on that it's expected in the
next Visual Studio for Mac updates
they're you know busy trying to unify
all their code with Visual Studio and
get all the common infrastructure in
place so they're taking took a little
bit longer for them to get their tooling
in place but it should be coming very
soon but you can use Visual Studio code
in the meantime can blazer work with
backends that are not dotnet absolutely
like if you have a blazer webassembly
app it is just a bunch of static files
you can host it on github pages you
could put it on as your static site
hosting and have whatever you want on
the server it could be Java on the
server it could be Python it could be a
fast typing monkey it doesn't really
matter because it's just a bunch of
static files that's gonna be downloaded
into the browser and run client-side ok
so then this question what kind of host
rainy verb later plays or you could put
it in Azure storage and make a static
website you could use Jekyll you could
put in and get out pages you are
nondenominational for the web assembly
version yes for the server version
that's an actual asp.net core app so
you're going to want to have actually
servers at that point that will that
will run on the server like we're going
to set up a signal our connection with
the server we highly recommend using the
azure signal our service actually with
laser server apps because they will
handle connections scale-out for you
thanks alright so next question what's
the underscore generated fie
when you created the code behind the
base class great question that's just an
artifact of how the tooling works in
order to drive the intellisense there
are multiple passes of code generation
that are occurring we actually hope in
the you know in a future release to
clean that up a little bit so you don't
see those generated files quite as often
as you do today part of that isn't
involved with us making the generator
components partial classes which is
coming in
daanyik or 3/1 excellent what else do
you think we have a several refresh yeah
any ideas about how many WebSocket
connections server-side Blaser can
handle well that's really depends on how
your server is set up if we use the
agile signal our service it will
multiplex all the connections to your
app and you can scale up to tens of
thousands of connections no problem the
connections may not be the real
bottleneck though most likely it's going
to be like memory on the server because
you are paying with your server
resources to actually run the UI for the
client so you've got to maintain all the
UI state and the you know the the
component instance is running on your
server so you're gonna have to plan for
that accordingly we have docs to help
you do that all right very cool so
what's the progress in website size and
there are a few point complaints but
it's too high the size of the website
yes yeah so Blaser webassembly is is
bigger like you have to bring a runtime
with your app there's a webassembly file
right now a default blazer webassembly
app like with our project template
weighs in at about two and two and a
half megabytes compressed things that
we're doing we're improving the io
liquor so we can strip out more code
right now we only run the IO linker on
part of the app we're going to run it on
more we think we can trim down the web
assembly file itself there's a bunch of
tricks that we're looking at we've even
talked about like taking the DLLs in and
stripping out all like the PE headers
and stuff like that so they don't so
that that stuff doesn't need to be
downloaded we have a bunch of tricks
that we're going to but to be clear it's
still just about about a megabyte or two
and is that compressed yeah that was the
compressed size and and I honestly I've
been to a lot of people's websites where
they're they have a PNG on their home
page that's that big 10 megabyte BM yeah
and I catch the file so you can put it
on a CDN
and how people only have to download
those ones because most of the time that
runtimes not going to change its the
same runtime no matter how much you're
iterating we love you but we have
to go alright so next up is xamarin
forms we're writing beautiful and more
productive xamarin ferns than ever with
David